logging was once a lucrative business
for better dictor a de brisee she'd
enter the forest illegally and
identified the trees to be felled she
employed two people for the work but now
she's given it all up a time came when
we were called to a meeting it was there
we were told about the ban on chainsaw
operations we were educated on several
ways in which we can live away from the
illegal activity now we have reached a
stage where we have no alternative but
to stop our legal activities walk away
walk the forest held almost 700 known
species of trees including several
mahogany varieties only 10% of the main
rainforest is left illegal logging cost
Ghana around 2.5 million hectares of its
tropical forest cover when addicted
ERISA is not the only one here who's
business depended on exploiting nature I
don't have any rights to enter the
forest it's an illegal activity in which
we were all involved if you succeed all
well and good if however you get
arrested by forestry officials or the
military you accept your fate Joanna -
no Kuni watch you for several years
Ghana has belonged to a voluntary UN
initiative to combat deforestation the
initiative trains people in local
communities and educates them about the
consequences of illegal logging activity
the program is also supported by the
European Union's community
representatives pass their knowledge on
to the people who live in forest
villages with one clear aim in mind
reduce the number of amount of illegal
timber that is being exported from ECP
countries to the European Union but
besides nature conservation the
initiative also guarantees fair trade
practices with Europe it also wants to
offer young people in the communities
legal opportunities in forestry local
communities and forest concession
holders are linked together that
enables them to adopt artisanal milling
skills to supply the domestic market
with legal timber we start to recognize
that we are doing more evil to the
forest damn good so we started to fill
the pink so far 7500 people in the
region have joined in the partnership
agreement people like with Ted Boateng
who was a sole technician he used to
repair chainsaws for the major logging
operators thanks to the UN's
environmental initiative has been able
to use his knowledge of wood to start up
a sawmill with cuts waste by recycling
the leftover products